[Music]
this is true I found out just before I
came out true story I was amazed to find
there's someone in our audience tonight
who has never seen any of the Star Wars
movies none of them true story
I'm fascinated I'd like to ask this
person some questions can we get this
person on camera no no no no no over
there over there yes right there
yeah yeah it's
it's me now wait a minute you've never
seen any of the Star Wars movies that's
right yes
then why the hell did you paint your
face like Darth Maul I'm sorry who's
that Darth Maul the villain from Star
Wars Episode one your face is painted to
look exactly like him oh you know it was
one of those crazy nights I just pointed
to a random picture at the tattoo parlor
and said I'll take that please
that's a permanent full-face Darth Maul
tattoo you have I'm afraid so let that
be a lesson never mix white wine with
cold minutes okay fine I just find it
hard to believe you've gone your whole
life without ever seeing any Star Wars
films or having any knowledge of them
I've all he's meant to see the movies
they're movies right I I just I never
cut around to it now I'm too busy
running a small venture capital firm
Millennium Falcon investments and
millennium falcon is the name of Han
Solo's ship from Star Wars no it's the
names of me and my partner his last name
is Falcon and your last name is
millennium no it's my first name plus
you could say I have a second full-time
job raising my two kids Palpatine and
our 5d okay wait a minute wait a minute
you've got to be kidding me
they're traditional Armenian names yeah
hang on hello PD hear me
hang on I'll raise the antenna
now I'll see you soon okay okay sorry
that's my lyft driver I have to leave
early grabbing dinner at the Skywalker
Ranch with my friend Jorge okay yeah let
me take a wild guess George Lucas yes
but your audience probably knows him
better as the executive producer of
Howard the Duck any duckets
[Applause]
[Laughter]
as they say in Armenia
haha look Andy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's my favorite part of any sketch
when they can't get it out the door
it's a landspeeder it can go anywhere
doors are hard
you